el 2021 ha traído los primeros datos
esperanzadores sobre la pandemia de
coronavirus desde inicios de enero se ha
producido una bajada de contagios
simultánea en varios continentes algo
que no había pasado hasta ahora the
number of reports case el soft el número
de casos reportados de kobe 19 a nivel
mundial ha disminuido por quinta semana
consecutiva last week show de la semana
pasada se vio el número más bajo de
casos semanales de octubre
october en lo que va del año el número
de positivos reportados semanalmente se
ha reducido al amigo lengua almost af en
europa a los confinamientos masivos han
ayudado a frenar la tercera ola causada
por las vacaciones de navidad y año
nuevo el continente ha tenido tres olas
de las que la de noviembre y enero han
sido las más fuertes pero tras la crisis
posterior a navidad el descenso ha sido
muy fuerte algo que ayuda en el proceso
de vacunación una situación similar se
está viviendo en eeuu el país más
golpeado del mundo por la enfermedad
aquí la llegada a la presidencia de joe
biden y su política de uso de
mascarillas han ayudado la nación
norteamericana ha vivido meses de crisis
sanitaria pero este 15 de febrero se
registró la
cifra diaria de contagios más baja desde
octubre y en américa latina' a una de
las regiones más afectadas la bajada
general también ha tenido lugar tras
haber sufrido dos grandes olas en agosto
y enero los datos mejoran después de que
algunos sistemas sanitarios estuvieran
al borde del colapso
los expertos no atribuyen esta mejora a
las vacunas ya que la mayoría de países
no han inoculado ni al 10% de la
población por eso advierten que la
prioridad es evitar la circulación de
nuevas variantes que puedan poner en
peligro la inmunidad colectiva que se
busca obtener con las vacunas